[Música]
llegó la hora hablar de salud en directo
américa de france 24 con más romero sala
ya está lista en el estudio más feliz
mañana de viernes hoy termina el foro
mundial de la migración entre otras
cosas para debatir los acuerdos sobre la
salud de las personas migrantes a los
que se comprometieron muchos países pero
no siempre los respetan más por supuesto
precisamente de eso vamos a hablar se
trata de un foro que termina hoy en
nueva york tienen muchísimos de estos
países que firmaron en 2018 el pacto
mundial para una migración segura
ordenada y regular en el marco de las
naciones unidas este pacto aborda el
tema de la migración desde muchas
aristas nosotros nos vamos a centrar en
el tema de la salud particularmente
podemos revisar uno de los artículos de
este pacto en el que habla de este
compromiso de garantizar el acceso a la
salud de las personas a migrantes e
incorporar sus necesidades sanitarias en
los sistemas de salud y facilitar un
acceso a pues a sin discriminación es
muy importante recordar que países no lo
firmaron también república checa hungría
polonia israel y estados unidos y luego
otros países como bulgaria o italia se
abstuvieron para precisamente son países
que reciben la lucha personas migrantes
pero por ejemplo españa que es otra de
las puertas de entrada a mucha migración
a europa si lo firmo sobre todo
migración africana mar le preguntó
entonces cuáles existen en españa en
términos de salud de las personas
migrantes pues se reconocen algunas de
mejoras sobre todo desde las leyes más
restrictivas de 2012 que quitaron la
sanidad universales sin embargo y
organizaciones como médicos del mundo
que recuerdan que para prestar atención
sanitaria se tiene que poder demostrar
que llevas tres meses en el país eso
excluye a muchas personas recién
llegadas y escuchemos lo que nos
comentaba su presidenta nuestras
personas que emigran tienen una atención
sanitaria puntual
que soluciona
[Música]
sus problemas de salud muchas veces más
importantes derivados del proceso
migratorio pero no solucionamos
realmente sus
necesidades entonces no cumplimos el
pacto un pacto que dice que estas
personas necesitan y tienen derecho a
una atención sanitaria durante su
proceso migratorio
en realidad
una vez que llegan aquí se les condena
una vida fuera del sistema sanitario y
esto provoca vulnerabilidad estas
palabras de nieves turienzo la estábamos
escuchando que nos hablaba de estas
vulnerabilidades de qué se trata pues
para empezar durante el proceso
migratorio falta de comida falta de agua
condiciones de salubridad negativas no
que pueden influir en la salud de las
personas también como impacta este
proceso migratorio en la salud mental es
algo que hemos repetido varias veces por
ejemplo hablando de los migrantes
refugiados ucranianos pero es que esto
lleva décadas sucediendo pues con otras
personas de otros orígenes también
cuando llegan a las fronteras problemas
de hacinamiento que pueden favorecer la
aparición de enfermedades infecciosas o
su propagación y luego como decías pues
de esta discriminación a la que se
pueden enfrentar cuando llegan
finalmente a su país de origen en este a
su país de destino perdón en este caso
españa donde pues muchas veces una
cierta discriminación o racismo hace que
estas personas queden apartadas del
sistema sanitario la norma la masa todo
el maltrato que sufren estas personas
que sabemos de la situación en el
continente americano pues en algunos
sentidos no es tan distinto aunque
algunas dinámicas diferentes por
supuesto recordemos que como decíamos
eeuu no firmo este pacto pero que vemos
que similitudes vemos por ejemplo el
tema del hacinamiento en estas zonas que
no son especialmente lugares donde la
salud sea la prioridad no tanto a
frontera en frontera de frontera de
méxico o de estados unidos también pues
todo este proceso migratorio recordemos
que muchas veces que las personas que
empiezan el proceso migratorio son
personas sanas y que este proceso es
finalmente lo que los pueden llegar a
enfermar y luego como decíamos cuando
llegan al país no sé si no siempre se
tiene este acceso a la salud por ejemplo
eeuu que al final es el principal
receptor de inmigración del continente
ahí en el 47 por ciento de los migrantes
indocumentados no cuentan con seguro de
salud eso es 8 veces más que los
ciudadanos estadounidenses sin embargo
no es el único país donde esto sucede
por ejemplo colombia que es el principal
país del receptor de emigración
venezolana aquí en colombia el 75% de
los migrantes venezolanos tampoco
cuentan con acceso a un proveedor
salud y en chile por ejemplo donde
también termina el viaje de mucha
migración venezolana la proporción es
algo más baja pero igualmente el 18% de
los migrantes no tienen acceso a la
salud algo que es cuatro veces más el de
la tasa de los nacionales chilenos con
estas cifras mar que nos acabas de
ofrecer porque tanta reticencia a
prestar el servicio de salud a la
población migrante pues normalmente el
argumento principal es el precio el
costo de atender a la salud de estas
personas pero precisamente desde médicos
del mundo nos ofrecían encontrar
argumentos
cuando estas personas no se atienden al
inicio de sus problemas de salud esos
problemas de salud se complican acaban
produciéndose situaciones más graves
terminan en servicios de urgencias
incluso con hospitalizaciones y eso es
muchísimo más caro
la atención inicial incipiente al inicio
de los problemas es muchísimo más barata
y es un error que ha demostrado la
pandemia la pandemia ha demostrado que
tener a personas fuera del sistema
nacional de salud ha hecho que esas
personas inicialmente no tuviesen acceso
a vacunas y no nos equivoquemos
proteger a esas personas pero nos
protege a todas las personas que vivimos
en este país hecho la pandemia es el
ejemplo perfecto de cómo tener grupos de
personas por ejemplo sin acceso a la
salud organizar ya nos afecta a todas
las personas que vivimos y eso pues
puede ser con la pandemia pero pueden
ser muchas otras cosas al final detrás
del argumento del precio muchas veces lo
que hay realmente pues son racismo y
discriminación es que no queremos ver a
la cara así es más muchísimas gracias
entonces como siempre por toda la
información de salud nos vemos el martes
con más salud porque pues no vengo el
lunes pero el programa obviamente sigue
bar y así los espectadores
así es mara isla vale vas a ver con
aquel a gómez mar feliz fin de semana
nos vemos entonces el martes vamos a
saludar a nuestra segunda mitad del día
para hablar precisamente de la pandemia